qui se souvient de son dernier rêve
érotique moi j'aimerais qu'on se dise un
truc il est 19 heures 29 c lundi parce
qu'après on va démarrer l'émission là ça
va partir
et là ça va plus s'arrêter là on va être
dans un jamais ça 19h29
j'aimerais vraiment qu'on sache ici et
vous aussi patrice corneille et
jean-marie si vous avez déjà fait un
rêve érotique à quelqu'un de connu 10le
maintenant ou taisez vous à tout jamais
si vous avez déjà fait un rêve érotique
à quelqu'un de l'équipe à will have a
intérêt à le dire et christine kelly
pourquoi il me regarde je le sais non
mais si a eu c'est très possible qu'il y
ait une télé dit clairement il en tire
dernier on sait tous que vous avez déjà
arrivé de monde ici je n'ai cherché
pendant tout leur est mais je n'ai pas
trouvé non ça ne vous dit pas non
maintenant alors non dit la vérité à
vous et à peine un mois et demi avec
delphine wespiser non les connards
j'aime beaucoup le montre extrêmement
lourd et c'est le seul mec dans un raid
le seul mec de 25 ans qui mangent à
l'eau chaude bien normal j'étais ok fait
fuir en voiture à gimont joue sous
contce tranquillement chez moi on
charolles et là que vois-je d'autres
sites de ce musée là avec son mec en
petite tenue d'ailleurs non et puis ce
qu'elle faisait elle me l'a fait la
danse du ventre s'est agenouillé sur moi
s'est stationné sur moi mon serment
brasse et non avant elle dit finalement
tu es un peu trop jeune pour moi et là
je me suis réveillé non je le suivrai
ces housses et ben voilà c'est sa belle
balade dans l'ascension voulais te
réveiller l'écologie lotois oui moi j'ai
fait un rêve érotique mange en effet
plein avec mathieu seul vous savez une
fois il ay s'est énervé s'est emporté
contre thierry moreau et après
l'émission c'était fatigué je dors de
qui je rêve pas tiennent en deux
matthieu delormeau thierry moreau et moi
dans un rêve érotique longtemps à
l'horreur ce n'est pas un rêve c'est ce
qu'on appelle un cauchemar
ces passionnés comment par rapport à toi
d'abord tous les deux ah ouais mais ils
se disputaient se battait un petit peu
et ensuite c'est devenu assez érotique
et après j'arrive à oued taria avec un
cycle vous dites la vérité c'est pas
vraiment érotique mais tous les six mois
je rêve que nous partons tous les deux
en goguette la date attendue
non j'appelle tout de suite la police
alors quoi c'est quoi l'histoire un très
bizarre tous les six mois
ouais vous l'avait raconté il ya un an
et c'est revenez jaser très vite surtout
les six mois je rêve que tous les dons
par en goguette dans un champ de blé et
que nous on élus dans l'assemblée n'est
ni dans un champ de blé en cours tous
les deux comme ça pour arriver des
filles en goguette sortie de deux amis
quoi ah oui oui je suis allergique c'est
de l'escourgeon précisément c'est très
allergique
ça coule un peu de partout et vous
trouvez des données oui j'ai rêvé de
belgrade
mais c'est parce que je suis très
souvent si la chorale j'ai rêvé lebel
rire et à soi mais un vrai beau ça
j'arrive et valery en caux allez une
salle à la amy ma 6 ie6 et dans un
tupperware
on avait fait ça je me suis un éminent
bâches en plastique en dessous de ce
qu'on mange salit
raconte je fais ça l'allemande est donc
un casque de chantier sur un échafaudage
et avec valérie en dessous abbas était
sorti ou dit la vérité arrêtez vous
coller avec maxime
enfin moi j'ai quelque chose de spécial
c'est que je contrôle mes rêves je dois
dire que si je veux rêver de vous oh
mais non merci j'ai pensé à vous avant
de dormir
ah oui et ça va se passer pendant la
nuit j'ai testé à peu près temps déjà
bon ah bon et alors où l'eau donc méfiez
vous je pense que max il est pas si
novices que ça non vous êtes ulla
pietzsch ont dans un même sac l'hadopi
c'est pour ça que depuis ce rêve l'âge
le néglige mois non non c'est vraiment
c'était il ya peut-être deux semaines
non et alors là avec vous ce faire non
non c'est bon c'est bon merci j'ai mes
amis j'ai mes soucis